welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul and the mold never
bothered me anyway cringy intro out the
way throughout this video we're going to
be breaking down archive 81 the new
camera based horror show that's designed
to make you shutter the season is packed
with a lot of cool reveals as well as an
ending that deals with some tiny wimy
wibbly wobbly stuff that you might not
be able to get your head around fear not
though we've gone through the tapes and
are here to bring you everything you
need to know about it bulls spoilers
from here on out and if you enjoy the
video then please hit that thumbs up
button and don't forget to subscribe to
be filled with a world full of spoilers
every week without the way thank you for
clicking this now let's get into archive
81.
okay so archive 81 is based on the
podcast show of the same name that
involves characters cataloging the tapes
of a missing filmmaker initially we
follow dan an employee of the museum of
the moving image who's tasked with
restoring severely damaged tapes that
were recovered from a building known as
the visa the job is given to him by a
man known as davenport the owner of a
dna ancestry company called wellspring
which was about bringing people together
much like the motto of that organization
davenport says that he wants the tapes
restored so that he can bring some
closure to those that were lost in a
blaze that burned the apartments down
however this is revealed to be a lie and
it turns out that devonport's brother
samuel was actually the leader of a cult
that wanted to bring a demon known as
kalego into our world thus he hires dan
and plays on his heartstrings because
dan shares a lot of similarities with
those caught in the blaze when he was
very young he too lost his family in a
fire and thus it seems like the perfect
job dan is somewhat of a recluse that
doesn't want anything out there online
about him and the archived building
which is located in the wilderness will
allow him to get away from it all
however as he starts to wipe away the
black mold from the tapes he discovers
something far more sinister whilst
watching them we learn the story of
melody a young filmmaker who documented
the visit and in doing so she honored
samuel's cult which lived there melody
was abandoned by her mother when she was
very young and it's revealed that this
is because she actually carries the
bloodline of a group of witches known as
the baldung coven they possess the
ability to thin the veil between
dimensions which will allow kallego to
come across and thus her mother left her
in a church so that she would be spared
this fate however samuel learned of this
and through melody psychiatrist steve he
lured her to the apartments now how this
connects to dan is that steve was his
father and he too learned of the cult
from melody he attempted to hide her
tapes away in storage but the baldung
coven ended up burning his house down to
stop the secrets of calego getting out
it's revealed that part of a comet known
as caron crashed on earth millions of
years ago and that this is named after
the ferrymen of hades who carried souls
across the river styx the comet passes
through our solar system every 70 years
and when this happens the walls between
our dimension and kalaego's thin which
allows the portal to be opened during
the middle ages the baldung witches all
got together and came up with a way to
trap kalego inside a statue and after
giving up their magic they've done
whatever they can to stop the entity
from getting out we learned that in 1924
a ritual to bring the demon across was
also carried out by a woman named iris
who used spirit photography to film the
presence of collago his prime vessel is
the statue that brings infectious mold
with it that has hallucinogenic
qualities this allows one to catch
glimpses into other domains where the
demon resides and it exists not only on
the tapes but also in the walls of the
visser itself when iris had the ritual
film she carried out a sacrifice and
this opened the veil between worlds that
allowed her to travel across into
kalego's domain it's said that tapes
films and photographs can capture things
invisible to the human eye and since
then the cult has built up around iris's
teachings in which they're trying to
bring kalego back through the use of
technology they want to use melody to
open up the doorway and having this
somewhat documented will create a guide
so that others can do the same now
mirroring this as dan starts to watch
the tapes cleaning the mold from them it
also thins the veils between realities
and he's able to connect with melody
across time and space just as he dreams
of her she starts to dream of him and
the pair become connected because it's
all connected i keep telling you all the
time every single video so sorry i had a
i had a bit of a thing in my throat
there now this mold also allows those
from the other side to somewhat
communicate with those in our world and
this is why those who are trapped there
are often brought across in art by those
who have come into contact with the mold
dan's sister plays the demonic prayer
known as purgatory on the piano and
melody's friend annabelle starts to
paint not only iris but also melody the
both of which we learn are trapped in
kaleco's dimension also i feel like
annabelle might be james one planning an
easter egg in the show but let me know
below if that's a reach either way
though the prayer purgatory of course
ties in with the timeless void that
kalego lives in and the rituals were
also somewhat shown in an unheard tv
show that dan restores known as the
circle this was actually created by a
man who found iris's footage and this
snuff film inspired him to make the show
though it wasn't ever released now the
symbol from this appears on the visa and
we learned that this was actually based
on the rituals of the cult carried out
by iris the vessel was actually built on
the ruins of her mansion which too
burned down during the ritual in which
they tried to bring kalego across the
room in which it was carried out in was
the only thing that survived and samuel
wants to do the ceremony once more in
order to finish the job with his
followers they slowly sink their teeth
into a young girl called jess who melody
wants to save from the building and
though steve tries to hide her away
whilst the sacrifice is carried out she
eventually returns to the visa in order
to rescue jess now they could all have
their different motives for summoning
kalego whereas iris wanted a child
there's others who want powers and
samuel ultimately wanted the demon to
reside in jess this is why one of her
helpers cassandra fed her mold and the
frequent seizures that she had were
actually caused by it in the final
episode we discovered that in the
basement of the visa a fire broke out
melody and samuel ended up entering the
other world where they have remained
trapped since now in the present dan
along with the help of his friend mark
track down annabelle who we learn was
given tapes by jess that no one knows
about dan uses these to bribe davenport
into letting him back into the compound
and here he and mark knock him out and
travel into the basement in order to try
and find a way to open the door to save
melody we learned that one of the
mysterious figures that had been on the
ground is actually melody's mother julia
and that she's spent 25 years trying to
get her back she's dreamt about melody
every night and has used davenport and
dan to thin the veil by playing the
footage so that the doorway can be
opened she uses her blood and a key to
open it once more sat down can travel
into the other dimension we discover
that kaleigo is mr lonely and though
people have tried to summon him all he
really wants to do is keep those that
enter his realm trapped there with him
in the void dan comes across an illusion
of his family and it's said in the
season that kallago can bring back the
dead and give you your heart's desire
which for melody is being reunited with
her mother dan finds her trapped in one
of kalego's illusions at the spot where
she was abandoned and she sat there
waiting for her mum to come back from
buying a pack of smokes for 25 years
though she's tied to this place dan
convinces melody that it's a [ __ ] lie
and the pair follow the sound to the
tuning four key that julia possesses in
order to escape melody makes it out into
the present and is reunited with her
mother but an actually ends up going
back to 1994 10 days after the visa fire
this is confirmed by not only the mtv
news report that chronicles the death of
kurt cobain but also by the twin towers
that are shown in the reflection of the
hospital window the nurse who sees to
him implies that he was found at the
site so the character probably came
through the doorway right after the fire
died down now i have seen some say that
this could be one of kalego's visions
but the strange floating specs of mold
are nowhere to be seen and if we look at
the podcast it too had a moment which
dan woke up in the city however since
its release the creative team have
spoken about how this isn't just
standard time travel which we'll talk
about in just a bit now before diving
into my own theories about what could be
happening i want to discuss what the
showrunner said in an interview with the
rap rebecca sunshine said that though a
second season hasn't been greenlit yet
the show was conceived as having
multiple entries and that they do know
where they want to go for the future or
the past now she also said that the
history of davenport and julia will be
unearthed in more depth so we can really
see what they got up to after 1994. now
an interesting thing that she touched
upon with davenport is that his motives
aren't as clear as you might assume
though rebecca didn't give too much away
she stated that he's quite an ambiguous
character and he could even end up
wanting to destroy the statue to lock
tolego away he clearly wasn't enamored
by his brother and it's possible that he
simply wanted to pull him from the void
before being done with the whole demon
summoning thing now we don't know where
samuel is but it is possible that he
traveled back to 1924 and who knows we
may even find out that he was linked in
with the creation of the circle now as
for what rebecca stated on the ending
she said that it wasn't strictly time
travel in an interview with the rap she
stated this is for us just a new spin on
time travel it's kind of going through
another dimension it's not what we think
of as time travel but there's so much of
the show that's about time and how it
moves and what it is is it a flat circle
is it an expanding universe is it a
block universe we don't know but the
adage of having this alternate dimension
puts a new playground in play i think
that what this means for dan is that
he's in an offshoot timeline similar to
what we saw in avengers 9 game or
something else that means that even if
he did go and stop 911 that it wouldn't
change things in our reality because
he's in a different universe similar to
this i think he won't be able to stop
his family from being murdered either
and i believe that when he attempts to
do this that this is how he will realize
that he's in a different reality however
his father will be there and melody
didn't form him before the portal was
opened that she'd been speaking with dan
thus one can assume that the one in the
alternate dimension would know that too
now samuel might also be in this
dimension as well but either way i think
that the second season will revolve
around melody trying to open the portal
once more so that she can save dan there
was also talk about the baldung handbook
which we know can't be burned because
iris told her brothers about it however
julia may possibly know of a way to
destroy it i think that she and melody
may attempt to track this down to put an
end to the rituals once and for all it's
gonna be interesting to see what they do
and overall i did really enjoy the
series it's one of those i think is
gonna either make you fascinated once
you learn the full premise of it or it
might turn you off it actually turned my
wife off when she learned it was about
demons and stuff and she was also turned
off because i've turned into a right
state since we got married however i was
really caught up in the mystery of it
and the season does a really good job of
blending a fan footage blair witch
project feel with more normalized horror
sensibilities there's a great mystery
here that you just want to uncover and
lots of things that will creep you out
without a reliance on cheap jump scares
overall i really can't wait to see what
comes next and the series gets a solid 8
out of 10. now i'd obviously love to
hear your thoughts and also what you
want to see in the series next comment
below and let me know and if you enjoyed
this video then please hit the thumbs up
button if you want some else to watch
then make sure you check out our
breakdown of why a certain scene in
ghostbusters afterlife is perfect which
will be linked on screen right now hope
to see you over there right after this
but if not you take care of yourself and
i hope you enjoy the rest of the week
thanks for checking out the video much
love peace
[Music]